قدم نواب يمنيون في الكنيست الاسرائيلي
تعديلا لقانون المواطنه الاسرائيليه يقضي
بترحيل وابعاد كل مواطن عربي يحمل الهويه
او الجنسيه الاسرائيليه وادين بتهم توصف
بالارهابي ونقلت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
انه في حال اقرار هذا التعديل فسيتم ابعاد
مئات من المواطنين العرب
والفلسطينيين العرب الفلسطينيين القاطنين
داخل الخط الاخضر والقدس المحتله الى
مناطق السلطه الفلسطينيه الضفه الغربيه
وكان التعديل القانوني قدمه نواب يمنيون
الاسبوع الماضي بينهم عميت هليفي عضو
الكنيست من حزب الليكود الذي يتراس رئيس
الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو والعضو في لجنه
الخارجيه والامن في الكنيست الذي نقلت عنه
الاذاعه قوله انه لا يعقل ان يحمل من تامر
على اسرائيل وامنها جنسيتها ويقيم فيها
وان القانون الجديد حال اقراره سيتيح
لوزير الداخليه مصادره حق المواطنه وطرد
كل شخص ادين بالارهاب سواء كان في السجن
حاليا او انه تحرر وانها
محكوميته معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري وليد نريد تفاصيل
اكثر حول مشروع القانون هذا وفرص
تمريره اولا هو القانون بخ هذا الخصوص كان
قد تم تمريره في الكنيست فيام عشر من
فبراير الماضي لكنه لم يتم تنفيذه وجاء
على
خلفيه الافراج عن الاسيرين ماهر
و من من ماهر يونس وابن عمه في حينه وهما
من منطقه وادي عاره وتم اخلاء سبيلهما بعد
ان امضيا اكثر من 30 عاما في السجن بعد ان
ادينا بعمليات قتل فيها اسرائيليين قاما
بها لصالح حركه فتح العضوان فيها حسب
لائحه الاتهام انذاك تمت اثاره هذا
الموضوع وسن القانون في ال عشر من فبراير
باغلبيه 994 صوتا لكنه لم يوضع قيد
التنفيذ وكانت المحكمه العليا قد
ردت طلبا بتفويض وزير الداخليه ليقوم بهذه
المهمه الان عادوا الى هذا الامر من جديد
بتقديم تعديل يفوض وزير الداخليه بسحب
الجنسيه من المواطنين العرب داخل اسرائيل
وكذلك من المواطنين الفلسطينيين في القدس
الذين يحملون الهويه الاسرائيليه من اجل
ابعادهم وابعاد عائلاتهم قضيه ابعاد
العائلات كانت قد سقطت في المحكمه العليا
ورفضت والان عادوا من جديد على خلفيه
الاوضاع المتصاعده
لاثارته هذا الامر كان قد تكرر مرارا خلال
السنوات الماضيه وليس بالضروره ان يكون
قابل للتنفيذ هذه المره ايضا لانه القانون
نفسه يقضي بان من يتم ابعاده يجب ان يكون
بحوزته جنسيه اخرى او في امكانيه لابعاده
الى دوله ونقلهم الى مطالبه بنقلهم الى
مناطق السلطه الفلسطينيه هذه عليها علامه
سؤال كبيره هذا ياتي في سياق ان السلطات
الاسرائيليه ومنذ بدايه هذه الحرب تقريبا
تدير الداخل الاسرائيلي ايضا وخاصه ما
يتعلق بالمواطنين العرب داخل الخط الاخضر
وكانهم تحت الحكم العسكري الاسرائيلي وليس
حكما مدنيا لحكومه جاءت هذه الاصوات من
قبل نواب يمينيين متطرفين في في اطار
محاولات تصعيد الاجراءات الانتقاميه ضد
العرب كافه سواء كانوا مواطنين في اسرائيل
ام هم فلسطينيين من القدس المحتله يحملون
ال قامه فقط او كما تسميهم اسرائيل مقيمين
اي هم يميزون بين مصطلحين بهذا الخصوص راح
وهو من يحمل الجنسيه مثل العرب داخل الخط
الاخضر و تشاف وهم مثل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين في القدس اي مقيمين هذا قد
يسهل عليهم ابعاد المواطنين من القدس
المحتله لكن قد يكون من العسير عليهم
تنفيذه داخل اسرائيل تحديدا لان من ادين
بتهم ارهابيه هو ليس فقط مواطنين عرب حتى
وزير الامن القومي الاسرائيلي بن كبير من
ضمن ال2 لائحه اتهام التي قدمت ضده في
الماضي كانت هناك ثمانيه ادين بها ومن
بينها ادين بالارهاب او دعم الارهاب فحتى
الان لم يتم تحديد هذا الامر بالنسبه لهم
ولكن من هم مستهدفون في ذلك هم امثال كريم
وماهر يونس وهم اسران سابقان قضايا في
السجن فتره طويله وايضا هناك وليد دقه
واخرون ممن كانوا قد قاموا بعمليات او
ادينوا
بعمليات تم فيها مقتل اسرائيليين و وتلقوا
كما يقولون مقابلا او مكافات او رواتبه من
السلطه الفلسطينيه كباقي الاسرى
الفلسطينيين في سواء في الضفه او قطاع غزه